well hello there you're watching the
press preview first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive
in the next half hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with the
journalists and author christina
patterson and the columnist at the
article ali mirage good evening t-bo
and we will see them in a moment but
first let's take a look what's on those
front pages and here is the daily mail
it says more than half a million doses
of the modern vaccine are heading to the
uk
and will be offered to the under 50s
next month
boris johnson has come under fire for
saying that people need to go back to
their offices after having had enough
days off during the pandemic that's on
the front of the observer
here's the telegraph it's reporting that
the government has launched an
investigation into
how elite schools have handled rape
culture claims
in the scotland on sunday the fallout
between alex salmond and nicolas
sturgeon is continuing with the first
minister criticizing her predecessor's
bid
to return to frontline politics
here's the express it hails a return to
normal life as covered restrictions are
slowly being lifted
and it's also on the front of the people
which is predicting a summer of love
as larger gatherings and weddings resume
well let's bring in christina and ali to
take us through the papers and shall we
start christina with the
with the observer tomorrow morning
talking about the prime minister being
irresponsible
i wonder if he's not um going to be
viewed so much as irresponsible because
the official guidance hasn't actually
changed has it it's just ruffling
feathers for saying
people have had enough days off because
many people have had to home school
and all sorts of things whilst working
from home haven't they
well yes but they haven't been having
days off in fact
quite the reverse i think most people
who have uh
have actual jobs those of us who are not
freelance um
and are have been working from home many
most of them for a year now have in fact
been sleeping in the office rather than
having holidays so it's deeply offensive
to people to suggest they've been
sitting around having a lovely time i
think many people are very keen to get
back to the office but what they are
also keen to do
is not in fact get infected and not
infect their loved ones
and we remember what happened last
summer when boris johnson
urged people to get back to the office
and said he wanted bustle and
basically suggested or sent ministers
out to suggest
that those who did not go back to the
office would be uh
looked upon less favorably by their
employers so
as always he is sending out inconsistent
messages
apparently with rishi sunak as well who
seemed to drive the second wave
in his refusal along with boris johnson
to he persuaded boris johnson not to
have the september
circuit breaker which could have had an
enormous difference so i think this is
very very unwise
boris johnson has said he'll be driven
by the data the data does not suggest
that it's yet safe for people to go back
to offices
we have to give schools priorities
schools are back infections
are rising among secondary school
children and we've just got to let that
settle we've got
many many unlookings to happen in the
next few months and officers should be
quite low priority
ali mirage do you agree with what
christine is saying there i mean it is
certainly
in contrast to what the prime minister
was also saying today about how
we're usually around three weeks behind
mainland europe in terms of cases so
seeming to suggest
that we might get another wave of
infections here just as he's saying
people have been
languishing at home well
isabel i think it was a slightly
unfortunate choice of words i don't
think anyone's been
having days off i hope i do agree with
christina completely i mean i've never
worked
longer hours in my life um because your
sort of days merge in
your work days merge into your personal
life so i think we're all suffering
mental health particularly people who've
been homeschooling kids as well i think
the prime minister is under a certain
amount of pressure
from his um back benches from the kovid
recovery group we know that 36
of them this week voted against the
extension of the
uh powers given to the government under
the covid uh coronavirus
act um until uh september the end of
september now they've extended their
their the powers that they can impose uh
which is sort of causing some
consonation amongst
backbench mps so he he's got to keep
them on board to a degree
and he also is conscious about getting
the economy back on its feet
we know that uh this year alone uh 350
billion is going to be
the borrowing bill and that rishi
sunait's got 2 trillion of
public debt to deal with so he clearly
wants to get people back into
work as quickly as possible but he has
also laid out very clearly that there is
a route to lockdown which we all
understand he says he's not going to
rush it he's going to be guided by the
data
and he's also pointed out that there is
a third wave in europe
europe is not doing well um compared to
us on the vaccine front so there are
dangers there so i think he needs to
behave
responsibly he's been doing quite well
this year in terms of
managing um the words that uh he utters
uh but i think this is a slight lapse
and i think i would urge him to address
it
okay uh let's turn our attention to the
sunday telegraph shall we
and you touched on it there ali and your
mention of the ongoing vaccine saga over
mainland europe this is a
sort of rao that's just not seeming to
go anywhere is it
talks are continuing between the uk and
the eu and this is a suggestion
that boris johnson will politely remind
the european commission of exactly how
much of taxpayers money has been
invested
into this job that everybody stands to
benefit from christina
yes well this vaccine rao doesn't seem
to be
going away i don't it has to be said
that you have not covered themselves
in glory i think ursula von der lion has
behaved extremely badly
and i think as as a someone who wrote
leopards at times i think it's the times
pointed out
it's the case of the eu wanting to have
their cake and not eat it
given how many uh astrazeneca vaccines
have been sitting in fridges completely
unused
while various eu leaders rubbish it i
think the
astrazeneca story is disgraceful
actually
here is uh in oxford university the team
heroic team
led by sarah gilbert who have done
phenomenal work that
may well save if not the world great
chance of the world because this is a
vaccine that
they are selling at cost price to great
swathes of the world
they have been the fact that they have
been discredited that their vaccine
their very good vaccine has been
completely gratuitously discredited by a
number of eu leaders
has been really disgraceful and will
have led to many thousands of deaths and
as anyone watching this knows i am very
pro-eu
and i am pro remain or where was claire
remain clearly that argument has been
and gone but
you know it it they have behaved very
badly on the other hand i just think
it's better to keep patriotism out of
these things germany will then say that
they funded fisa which they did
i think the important thing is to come
to an agreement
that will keep infection levels reduce
infection levels across the eu and
ultimately across the world
we've already exported our uk variant to
the whole of europe and
that's why they're suffering their third
wave so let's be diplomatic let's not
let's not do all this flag waving and
let's just resolve this as quickly as we
can
okay ali what do you make of that how
helpful do you think it will be to bring
in
to the equation the expenses to the
taxpayer i mean maris
sefkovic is being quoted in the sunday
telegraph as saying that it should be
taken into consideration that that
seemed fair enough but as christina's
pointing out germany
will argue the same when it comes to
pfizer
well i do think it's a fair point that
the uk government is making
i mean look no one wants a vaccine war
right now and neither side really want
to cross the rubicon i mean i
i noticed this week that the the
rhetoric was being toned down on both
sides and they were talking about
uh developing some sort of win-win um
situation that would work for both
parties i mean from the eu side
they have exported 77 million doses of
vaccine
abroad and they've only actually put in
put in people's arms 88 million
themselves now
of the 77 million 21 million of those
have come to the uk
so they're feeling that in terms of
supply chains and the contracts they
have signed they're not being honored
now that's a
an issue for them to deal with with the
the corporates that they sign those
agreements with
i think the reality is the eu has
handled it quite badly we know that
emmanuel macron only in january was
saying that the
the astrazeneca jab was quasi
ineffective for the over 65s he's now
reneged
sort of down a vault fast on that we
know that angela merkel was also in the
germans we're also talking about blood
clots
uh being caused now that's also been a
reverse so
the eu has not had its finest hour on
vaccine rollout
and we know that they're very sensitive
about retaining vaccines we know that
mario draghi or
the prime minister of italy dubbed super
mario
is uh is retaining 250 000 uh
doses that were meant to go to australia
so i think this is going to rumble on
for a while i do think it makes sense
for
pragmatism on both sides and i expect
that that will win the day i think boris
johnson has been quite careful
in turning down the rhetoric on this and
trying to be pragmatic and practical
at the mail focusing on the news that
will potentially ease the pressure on
the astrazeneca round that is that the
moderna
vaccine which has been approved for some
time in this country is finally going to
be coming on stream
in three weeks time which is great news
for the under 50s as i i've got lots of
friends in the under 50 category getting
to feel a little bit twitchy
that they might be left out of this
world-beating vaccine roll-out tell us
more christina
yes well this is very good news and it
is miraculous actually that this time
last year
we didn't have a vaccine and when you
think of how many diseases
how many decades it has taken to develop
vaccines there's still no vaccine for
hiv and that's 40 years on it is
absolutely miraculous that the
scientists have come up with
quite a few functional vaccines and i
think by the autumn there'll be several
more so
wonderful news that modern is on its way
and according to the trials it's a very
very effective vaccine pretty much along
the lines of pfizer as far as we can
tell that we don't
obviously have real real-time data
on it yet but great news and with any
lark
if we control our borders effectively by
the autumn
things will be looking a lot better well
that brings us neatly on to the next uh
story this back on the front of the
telegraph ali about a quarantined
traffic light system
uh when we're looking at summer holidays
and of course we're all talking about
the border issues at the moment but that
issue
needs to be addressed in the summer as
well will people be able to go abroad or
not what are the telegraphs saying
well the telegraph is saying that there
are sort of analysis being done about
this traffic-like system
of um categorizing countries depending
on their vaccination rates
and their level of infections into amber
green
and red etc um which will give some
people
a scintillate of hope that their summer
holidays are still on the table
the government's been blowing a little
bit hot and cold on this issue
i think this telegraph story is going to
certainly give people hope
because people are desperate to um to
get away i think a lot of people are
just feeling
completely exhausted uh by being cooped
up at home so i think
the the uk tourism industry is going to
also have a boost but this is uh
also very important for people to be
able to go away i mean we know that the
tour
the travel and tourism industry concept
contributes about 200 billion a year
uh to the uk economy about 10 of gdp so
it's very very important airports
airlines
hotels etc all uh really struggling at
the moment so it is very important the
government looks at this and it looks
like
um if you're if you're in from a green
country you could just come in
uh that's absolutely fine but it also
brings us to that whole issue about
vaccine passport
and living in a sort of a biosecurity
state and how the government is actually
going to
play that and explain it to people
because we haven't really had the debate
about
how long all these restrictions are
going to last how we're going to come
out
and what it means in terms of vaccine
passports
biosecurity going forward liberty of the
individual i think the government needs
to have that debate
quite openly with the public and lay out
a roadmap okay ally and christina we'll
leave it there we're going to take a
short break and we'll be right
back with you after the break we'll be
looking at the rest of the papers
including this one
where we can see the first minister of
scotland uh nicholas sturgeon saying
salmond no longer fit to stand for
public
office that's in scotland on sunday that
and the rest of papers
in a couple of moments welcome back to
the press preview with me now christina
patterson
and ali mirage um ali let's start with
the observers shall we they're leading
with the photograph
of this protest today it was armed
forces day a national holiday but of
course this comes in the wake
of the military coup on the 1st of
february and today the deadliest day
since then international condemnation
and the foreign secretary dominic rob
describing it as a new low
indeed um you know over 100 people
killed and we've had over 400 people
killed since the beginning of this
coup in february um i mean
uh the former de facto leader of the
country won a landslide victory in
november
we know that she's had a very difficult
struggle
to try and sort of install some sort of
semblance of democracy
in myanmar she was under house arrest
for 15 years of course as we know and
won her first election in 2015. so this
is really a retrograde step we're moving
backwards i think the international
community
is clearly imposing sanctions but as you
can see
from the military parade yesterday uh
the russians and the chinese are sort of
putting their own spin on it i mean the
russian sent a ministerial official
there
um so it's kind of going to be
interesting to see how this plays out
but certainly very dark days
for myanmar and we don't know where ang
sensuchi is or
uh where when she gonna be put on trial
or make a return we have no idea
and christina the tragedy of all of this
of course is the civilian deaths
many of them children a five-year-old
today
in our report this evening by siobhan
robbins a baby who'd survived but had
received a shot in the eye
and the junta warning earlier in the
week that protesters
would be there on the receiving end of
military aiming for the head
i mean this is just unimaginable
brutality
i was just uh we were just going on a
short committed
walk a small short drive away this
morning and i heard on the radio
about the children being who had been
killed
by the in the demonstrations and
can you imagine if that happened in this
country i mean we've got
plenty of controversy about our own
demonstrations at the moment but
that's about bruises for the most part
the idea that you would actually
fire on children and babies on anyone
for that matter but on
children and babies it is it's just
breathtaking and
i'm glad that the observer have put this
on the front page because
too often these reports are relegated to
a tiny news and brief on the foreign
pages and
we we really mustn't look away we
because we have we are
all grappling with the tragedy of kobe
but that doesn't mean that we can
turn our backs on atrocities like this
and i just
hope that somehow or other this
government this military regime this
coup
will be held to account because we
really
you know it's just breathtaking that
these things are happening in the world
absolutely breathtaking couldn't agree
more um let's finish
ali on this story in the front of this
the scotland on sunday
sort of portraying the politics in
scotland as something of a psycho drama
with nicola sturgeon who's just survived
this vote of no confidence
calling her predecessor unfit to return
to frontline politics
well they were very very close um and
they were a formidable combination and
now they're an open civil war
um in the nationalist movement i mean
alex salmon this week launched his
alba party i must say i thought alba was
the manufacturer of
a sort of reasonably priced electronic
goods uh rather than a party but
he's called it alba he wants to make a
comeback he's going for
regional list seats in the scottish
parliament and hoping to at least win
his own seat
um so it's an interesting psychodrama as
you say
uh nicholas sturgeon had a good week
last week she was cleared of any
sort of uh misleading or or or not not
breaching the ministerial
code if you like but it's been a pretty
sorry state of affairs for the
nationalists and we'll have to see how
it all plays out we will indeed it
doesn't look as though alex salmon has
the same sort of popularity as nicolas
sturgeon at the moment but
we have to leave it there ali mirage and
christina patterson i don't know where
the time's gone it's really good to talk
to you we'll do it all again in a little
while thanks so much for joining